[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he is the voice of sunday night football
and all of a sudden i got to call him
hall of famer now
recipient of the 2021 ford frick award
for baseball broadcasting al
michaels look at you congratulations
look at you
yeah i'm not winning anything
you're a freaking hall of famer now i
can say that al
you know it's it's pretty amazing
because i haven't done a baseball game
in 25 years except uh kostas and i did a
one-off
in san francisco for mlb network back in
i think 2011 or 12.
so you know i loved baseball i built my
career around it i did it between 1968
when i started in the minors in hawaii
and through 1995 and uh it's
you know i don't have any regrets in my
career i mean i've had a heck of a run
here and
been in a lot of fantastic places at the
right time
but if there's one small regret it said
i was never at
the network that had the rights to
baseball after 1995. i loved
doing it been a long time uh had a lot
of you know good fortune
cincinnati reds when you're you know
you're up there in dayton and listening
to me as a
as a kid doing the reds the big red
machine 71-73 then the giants then
monday night baseball and all of the
rest
uh it was great i loved it and uh and
then to have this happen to me
uh was fantastic and uh they announced
it on mlb network yesterday and then
our great good friend mr costas came
came on and we did a little two-way and
had a lot of fun he's already
playing the itinerary for cooperstown in
july you know bob
uh we won't be eating anything that has
gluten in it but apart from that it
should be a heck of a weekend
if i said at age 22 you got to choose
one sport to broadcast
what would you have chosen baseball no
question
uh you know when i got out of arizona
state and i had i had gone there
specifically because the
radio and tv program was so good i got
to announce
baseball football basketball but the
football team had
charlie taylor curly culp coached by
frank kush the basketball team at
jumping joe caldwell
and the baseball team had sal bando rick
monday
and then reggie jackson came along so i
loved baseball
i got my job in hawaii because i brought
a tape to the man who was running the
team a man by the name of jack quinn i
only wish he was still alive to see this
he gave me the first break and so i have
an audition tape
in which sal bando is in the game reggie
jackson is a
freshman i'm talking about him coming up
the next year because freshmen were not
eligible
you got rick monday and that's how i
wound up getting the hawaii job and
that was the trampoline and off we went
so i looked back and i can't believe uh
you know
it's been that long it's a long long
time ago
and uh had a little email exchange with
johnny bench today so
you know a lot of memories are flowing
back right now
and there's a certain cadence though
well you could tell
tell us better than i can try to
describe it but you know you've done
everything but if you're looking for
that you get into a rhythm
the sport that's the hardest to get into
a rhythm and the easiest to get into a
rhythm
i think baseball is the most satisfying
especially on radio
because of its rhythm uh if you look at
football
especially you know on television
football you've got four seconds of
action
and then if they run the clock out you
know like 35 seconds of of
inaction and normally that's where the
analyst comes in and
does the replay uh there's a there are a
lot of things as you know
in a football telecast uh a lot of
traffic
that you have to handle so it's it's
difficult in that sense to really get
into the stories
basketball and hockey are continuous so
that's
very difficult as well baseball's
different it's a stop and a start
and it gives you a lot of leeway and a
lot of freedom to talk about a lot of
different things and you know these days
the games are going over three hours so
you have
plenty of time it's played every day so
i would say
for me baseball was always the easiest
because of that
uh hockey's the hardest no question
about it i mean
uh the great mike emerick retiring this
year and nobody
did it better uh i mean he was fantastic
to be able to do what he did and you
know mike started on radio as well
and i think a lot of the great
announcers um
or you know the guys who have reached
the the pinnacle got their start in
radio
you learn to paint pictures and i see a
lot of the young kids are coming up
right now they're going right to
television
so i don't know what's going to happen
in the future but i do know that those
of us who you know
marv albert and and mike emerick and the
guys who you know have come up
through the years we all got our start
in radio and i think that was
tremendously beneficial
what was your first professional game
like as a broadcaster
well it was uh i guess minor league
baseball in hawaii
uh in 1968 i guess that would count as
the beginning i went over there and uh
we're playing the the eugene emeralds i
think larry boa was playing in that game
and
the greg lucinski and joeliss and people
like that uh
i was very nervous but you know i had
grown up in brooklyn and then
our family had moved to los angeles
ironically the same year the dodgers
came to l.a so i never missed a beat
and i've been listening to vince scully
since i was six years old and
by the way one of the great calls i got
yesterday on the on the answering
machine
it's vinnie congratulating me you know
joining the club and we had a great
conversation
last night i mean when i think of you
you
you know you need a mentor and in a way
vinnie was my mentor because from the
time i'm six
until i go to hawaii and start my career
he's the voice i hear in my ear
and i probably tried very hard to
imitate vinnie when i started and then i
had to kind of find my my own
path uh and my own cadence and
i didn't want to sound exactly like
benny but clearly he was
he taught me baseball by listening to
him all of those years
um he taught me you know pretty much how
to broadcast
and then you know through the years like
i got very lucky too i mean i had so
many
great mentors bobby winkles was the
coach at arizona state
he would go on to manage the white sox
cas and the angels at different times
in hawaii in hawaii chuck tanner is the
manager
so and he would go on to win the we are
family world series with pittsburgh
in 79 i go to the reds i mean think
about this i've got sparking anderson
pete rose johnny bench tony perez joe
morgan
you think i learned a little bit about
baseball there and one of the great
things for me is that in the three years
in cincinnati
i had to do a sparky anderson 10-minute
radio show every day so i had at least
10 minutes with working
the main spark it was called what the
main you remember the main
spark brought to you by maybe stro's
beer at that time of course you remember
it
but i would have to you know sparky and
i would at least have 10 minutes
alone to tape the show which always
which very often turned into like a half
an hour
so i got a phd from sparky and think
about this because we did
not only every regular season game we
did all 30 uh spring training games and
the reds got to the playoffs
twice into the world series once when i
was there so i probably did 600 shows
with sparky anderson and that's how i
got my phd in baseball
and you bring up a great point we're
talking al michael's uh sunday night
football play-by-play now
baseball hall of famer the recipient of
the 2021 ford frick
award for baseball broadcasting learning
on radio
because radio really i fell in love with
doing this
by listening to radio whether it was you
marty brennaman and joe nuxall uh
listening to talk shows pete franklin
out of cleveland
you know i was very i was fortunate but
i'm listening and the power of the
of just listening to words and then
creating
your own picture whatever that might be
is really powerful and i was never able
to master a play-by-play
but it did help me in communicating in
what i do
on this show and that is don't take it
for granted they know
what you're talking about or what it
looks like you've got to make sure you
explain it to them and always think of
the
radio listener more than the tv viewer
no question and especially in in in my
era
in cincinnati there weren't that many
games on television so
the vast majority of games were radio
only on wlw
and i would always picture you know
maybe a guy
sitting on a porch in corbyn kentucky
you know having a beverage and sitting
out there you know in the twilight
in the summertime and i was kind of
doing the game for him it's so much
different now of course on television
and with social media and with streaming
and all of the rest
it's so it's so much different but if
you go back to to that
point in time you're exactly right it's
radio i mean to this day
i think about you know we go back to
vince kelly for a second
and vinnie did the games until you know
four or five years ago so vinnie was in
his late 80s
when he stepped away and he was still
phenomenal and i can't tell you
you know i'm listening to him from the
time i was six until the time you know
i'm
benny's 88 years old in his last season
and i'd be driving you know back home
from someplace and vinnie would start to
tell a story and i'd have to
i'd have to put the car i stopped the
car in the driveway
keep it idling and just hear the rest of
the story that's how compelling
vinnie was he was just the master of
that uh
to the day he retired and uh it's it's
so true
this is where you really you know cut
your eye teeth
earn your chops or whatever you want to
say about it but radio is the way to go
it's so much different right now as we
know i also
as strange as this may sound the
greatest call you ever had
with a baseball game had to do with the
89 earthquake
when there was no action on the field
but there was so much action around you
your composure like you handled that
like
you were peter jennings i mean you
handled it like a news man
and and you knew the area but that might
have been your greatest call
at a baseball stadium al it was
certainly
the the oddest uh you don't rehearse for
an earthquake in the middle of the world
series
let's put it that way so for starters uh
tim mccarver and jim palmer and i are
doing the game we're just happy we
weren't thrown out of the booth
when it stopped shaking so uh you had
that petrifying
few seconds and then all i thought to
myself you know you kind of go back
almost to the
to the 10th grade when i'm taking a
journalism class
and the tenets of journalism are who
what when where
and how and why and i remember thinking
okay this is
this is very different be calm
just keep focused and don't go to a
place that you don't belong
uh only talk about the things you know
for certain
and it was kind of crazy because we're
getting information coming from
this this source and that source and
this is 1989
you know pre-everything uh today if it
was an earthquake
twitter would have it within two seconds
at that point
in san francisco one of the ironies of
that
night is that the earthquake took place
at 504
at about 5 20 people still don't really
know
what took place they knew it was an
earthquake but candlesticks enclosed you
can't see outside
they don't know what's really going on
and the crowd starts to chant
play ball play ball they had no idea
what had taken place
so i had an id obviously because we had
the blimp and i could see certain things
and all i talked about that night was
what i knew for certain
because we're getting all kinds of
misinformation that's coming in and i'm
going no no no no
we have to get all of this corroborated
so it's it's again it's a case of and
it's another thing that i always thought
about in broadcasting
then less is more sometimes because
where you get into trouble as you go
into places where you don't belong
so i i told you what i knew for certain
i'd lived in that area for a lot of
years so i certainly had i
geographically i knew what was going on
i had a feeling for what was
taking place you know in the in the bay
area at that point
and i only went to places that that i
belonged that i knew about
were you ever told to evacuate because
you guys are up high
we were so what happened was uh
everybody was kind of milling around and
then they postponed the game
at about close to 5 30. so at that point
the stadium emptied out uh
orderly i mean the the earthquake no
there was no more shaking
and i went down because we did not have
communication
uh to the extent that we needed it in
the booth
so they brought me down to the truck and
i did most
of the um analysis that night
from the production truck and they
haven't had they had a microphone in
there
which i looked at the tape a few times
obviously
and it looked like something sinatra
would have used you know if he was in a
cabaret
it was all sparkly and you know but it
just looked like
something a guy would would be singing
at a nightclub into
so i had that and i was there for a
number of hours right
in fact they kept me there until after
four in the morning because they wanted
me to go on good morning america which
started at seven
eastern time so um it was quite the
night it was a memorable night it was
unbelievable and
uh you know i'm just uh look
people say was that a great thrill for
me no it wasn't a great thing
it's a tragedy that was a tragedy people
are dying
uh billions of dollars of damage and all
that i wish it had never happened
but you know when something like that
happens you just have to be you hope
that you're equal to the task and
and at least i was able to hold the fort
down until they were able to get the
news people out there proud to know you
proud to consider your friend and uh
very happy for you al
uh thanks for joining us we appreciate
it
dan any time you know that thank you i
just hope i give you a little bit of a
raiding spike
i was going to have costas on to talk
about you i thought i might get a rating
spike
with that but uh no thank you thank you
that's al michaels